en premier lieu le détournement
intervenue au début de l'après midi
entre athènes et paris détournement d'un
airbus de la compagnie air france venant
de tel aviv avait près de 250 passagers
à son bord pour un tiers des passagers
israël l'airbus de l'état arrivé à
roissy cet après midi à 14h35
il avait quitté l'aéroport de tel aviv à
9h ce matin israélienne à 11h25 heure de
paris l'avion fait une escale à athènes
après avoir embarqué 57 personnes dans
les terroristes très certainement il
repart avec 246 passagers 83 sont de
nationalité israélienne il ya également
un bébé à bord
quinze minutes après le décollage
l'appareil disparaît des écrans radars
de la tour de contrôle d'athènes le
contact radio est coupée on apprend peu
après que l'avion était détourné qu'il a
été contraint de mettre le cap sur la
libye
à 15 heures heure française arbus se
pose sur l'hérault drôme de bengazi et
va ce parc est en bout de piste
quelques heures après les autorités
libyennes montabord la négociation
semble s'engager
bien que soumis à une surveillance
spéciale l'aérodrome d'athènes a déjà
été le théâtre de plusieurs attentats et
détournements au cours des trois
dernières années
selon la radio israélienne les pirates
de l'air serait au nombre de cinq ou six
une organisation inconnue revendique ce
détournement
le front populaire radical de libération
de la palestine pour tel aviv ce sont
les autorités françaises qui doit
décider des mesures à prendre pour
libérer les otages et à paris le
ministère des affaires étrangères a
demandé à l'ambassadeur de libye
d'assurer la sécurité de tous les
passagers
quand l aérodrome de bengazi en juillet
73 des terroristes palestiniens avaient
fait exploser le boeing de la japan
airlines qu'ils avaient détourné après
avoir fait évacuer auparavant les
passagers
a roissy cet après-midi on attend d'elle
et quand tu y étais des nouvelles du vol
air france 139 premier avion français
des tournée au proche orient
aujourd'hui laurent chefs des partis
cdfa l'avion revient ma ce moment là on
pourra récupérer notre famille
le problème c est qu on puisse avoir eu
très vite une solution pas sont restés
comme ça et sur cet îlot de peut-être
datant mais il fallut attendre et
espérer repartir
non jamais
là trois heures j'étais inquiet bien sûr
évidemment un
surtout ce sont là dans l'état dans
lesquels se tournent concerts tous les
matins ce qui se passe et pourquoi